Speaker 1: let's go next to Bobby from
Savannah. Is that Savannah, Georgia, Bobby?
Speaker 4: Yeah, it is, actually. That's great.
Yes, I can. OK, well, I just want to get quick,
because I have to go to work soon. It's a real
simple question because I know you've been
talking to your audience about incentives to get
people who are hesitant to get vaccinated. Right.
And I noticed I even saw this on Twitter. I think
New York City, they're actually going to give one
hundred dollars to people who get vaccinated.
I don't understand why we can't just do
a thousand dollars from the federal government
if you get vaccinated or a thousand.
Speaker 1: Seems like a lot. I don't
know that. I don't know the math of
it. A hundred. Is it a hundred dollars
cash or a one hundred dollar tax credit?
Speaker 4: Any way, any tax credit, I think
the one in New York is a they're going to give
whoever gets vaccinated one hundred dollars on the
spot. Wow, I could be wrong. I just saw that. But
I don't understand why we aren't just paying
people to get vaccinated at this point. Yes.
Speaker 1: I haven't I haven't heard about the New
York thing, but I think financial incentives would
be fine for people who say, oh, we can't afford
that. Listen, we can we can actually figure out
for a given unvaccinated population what is the
likelihood of a hospitalization, death, all of the
associated costs and including productivity loss
and loss of tech. You could figure out and you
could be like, OK, for the average ten thousand
person population, we expect to spend X amount
of money. Divide that by ten thousand. Let's just
give that to people and then you that I think that
the math would favor something like that. It my
instinct is a thousand dollars is not the number,
maybe it's one hundred. But that's very
interesting if that's what's being done.
Speaker 4: I mean my main thing about the thousand
dollars is I'm just basing it off like the
stimulus checks. But regardless, like the amount,
if we go under lockdown again, we're going to have
trillions of economic productivity. Absolutely.
No. And I don't think even all these people who
will position and virtue signal about
not wanting to take the vaccine,
I don't think they'll put up those excuses.
If they have the option to get a thousand,
Speaker 1: that may be that might be. I mean, I
think the other thing you have to remember also,
Bobbie, is that there's lots of states that are
never going back into lockdown no matter what.
So so it's also, you know, that for better
or worse. But there are states that have made
it clear no matter what happens, we're
not putting any any guidelines back on.
Speaker 4: I mean, if I feel like if another
screen comes out that the vaccine doesn't work,
I mean, I'm a medical student and my understanding
is that this belt variance coming is more
infectious. But there could always be some sort of
mutation in this protein that is associated with
the vaccine and it kind of void the actual target.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there could be a vaccine evading
variant. Delta is here. 90 percent of
US cases now, I believe, are Delta. And
you're right that it's relatively well
handled by the vaccine. Yeah, of course,
those states could change, but I like the
idea. Do a tax credit or cash on the spot
when people complete a vaccination dose. Why not?
Speaker 4: Yeah, and plus, I think especially now
I do think there's still probably issues regarding
unemployment, stuff like that, people still need
money. There are portions of this nation like I'm
from the south, everything's back up. But I know
in other parts of the country, there's a little
bit more got more guidelines and more restrictions
that are leading to whether it be
workers, business owners not having enough
access to just demand overall access to demand.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen, things are that's
a different that's a different thing. For the most
part. Businesses are businesses are open, things
are open and so on and so forth. But things are
going to get very ugly if we don't get more people
vaccinated. So I appreciate you bringing it up.
Speaker 4: OK, thanks.
Speaker 1: All right, thanks so much,
appreciate that. There's Bobby from Savannah.